Oh,
we've started to talk about
existentialism from the perspective of
the individual,
but it's necessary to also understand
the individual in relationship to the
hole.
And when you're speaking about
existential
personality theory,
it's even more important to place the
individual in a broader context.
And the reason for that,
at least in part is because
it's while it's for two reasons,
is it's that the initial existential
theorists,
most particularly Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky,
we're very interested in the political
consequences of inauthenticity now need
you to believe that it was the drive for
truth that had been hyper developed in
Europe,
at least from a technical perspective by
European submission to Cath Wallace for
thousands of years that eventually
overthrew
Christianity in its dogmatic form.
But he also believed that the
consequences of that would be
the weakening of the individual human
being,
at least initially who was then more or
less cast adrift,
but even more importantly,
that there would be dire political
consequences.
And he was particularly concerned about
the potential for collective
collectivist thinking to exert a
murderous hold over the modern world.
Now,
interestingly at exactly the same time,
it's so remarkable how much niches,
life and Dostoyevsky's life parallel one
another.
It's really as if they were two sides of
the same person because Nisha was
philosophizing more or less explicitly.
Well Dostoyevsky who's exploring exactly
the same themes in his writing.
And there's multiple forms of this
parallelism.
So for example,
when Nisha was,
the idea is that nature was working out
and beyond good and evil.
We're the same ideas that possessed in
many ways that possessed Dostoyevsky's
character ruskell called Nikolaihov in
crime and punishment,
which is a pretty nice parallel title to
go beyond good and evil.
And then even more interestingly,
dusty minsky wrote a novel called the
possessed or the devils,
which I think is the least accessible of
his great novels.
Um,
it about,
you know,
Dostoyevsky's great novels are very
long,
like great Russian novels tend to be,
and they have a very large cast of
characters and all of the characters
have three names,
plus they have nicknames.
And so it's quite difficult to keep
track of them.
And it takes quite a long time.
I think for a modern reader,
especially one who's not familiar with,
with with Russia or Russian literature
to,
to have it all come together in a
coherent narrative hole.
And that's most pronounced I think in
his book the devils.
But the devil's is an unbelievably
interesting book because it describes
individual psychopathology and in some
ways the same way that dusty Husky does
it notes from underground,
but it links it to this susceptibility
to a certain kind of,
uh,
political extremism and utopianism in a
very direct way.
And so in nodes for underground for
example,
the main character is very
psychologically week,
partly because he doesn't believe in
anything.
And so because he doesn't believe in
anything,
even if he's offended,
even if he finds something,
um,
unacceptable,
personally,
he finds it very difficult to stand up
in,
up in opposition to it or even to stand
up for himself because he's so full of
doubt that he questions everything he,
he does.
And Dostoyevsky presents the main
character in notes from underground as
someone who's fragmented to the point of
radical uncertainty.
Now his characters in the devils have
the same underlying problem,
which is in some sense the demolition of
the integrity of their personalities by
the collapse of their formal individual
and collective belief systems.
But instead of becoming riven by
uncertainty,
and doubt,
they become possessed by certainty.
And hence the name the devils are the
possessed.
I mentioned to you at one point that
young famously claimed that people
didn't have ideas,
that ideas had people,
which I think is one of the loveliest
lines I've ever come across.
It's,
it's,
it's so brilliant,
but Dostoyevsky's novel,
the possessed is about how ideas have
people.
And his main character in that novel,
if I recollect properly,
is named Stavenhagen and staff Oregon is
the kind of nihilistic thinker who turns
to totalitarianism.
And basically what happens in the
devil's is that he turns to precisely
the ideas that also manifested
themselves in radical Marxism.
And then later,
because the possessed was written quite
a bit before the death of the czar and
the Russian revolution,
you know,
several decades before that.
But Dostoyevsky felt that these ideas
were in the air in some sense as an
alternative to classical European
thought,
including not only classical religious
but also classical enlightenment
thought.
Now,
tolstoy wrote a book called confessions,
which I would very much recommend
reading.
It's a very short book and hidden
confessions.
What happens to tolstoy as he talks
about his experience in Russia when the
news of the death of God,
in some sense swept across Russia in,
uh,
in us,
a sudden storm.
The Russians had been futile for a very
long period of time and they were
backwards in many ways compared to the
rest of Europe.
And they had stuck in their mid evil
cultural form far longer than most
European states.
But when that collapsed,
it collapsed with amazing sudden with,
with amazing instant tenacity.
And tolstoy writes in the confessions
about remembering when the idea first
dawned on him and many other people
simultaneously,
that the entire edifice of Orthodox
Christianity was no longer tenable.
And then what happens with tolstoy and
confession is that he describes his
absolute collapse as a integrated
psychological being in his descent into
the underworld,
roughly speaking tolstoy at the height
of his success.
And he was the most successful author in
the world at one point.
Certainly.
And perhaps,
you know,
people still argue that maybe he was the
greatest author,
whoever lived,
although I think Dostoyevsky deserves
that title,
but I'm more of a psychologist and a
sociologist and tolstoy who was a
sociologist.
Tolstoy was unwilling to wander around
his estates with either a gun or with a
rope nearby because he was afraid that
he would either shoot or hang himself.
And it's because he,
despite his fame and his greatest states
in his political,
uh,
his political work,
he was very interested in the
emancipation of the serfs.
For example,
he concluded in some sense that life was
an evil joke.
It was as if life was an evil joke,
being played on mankind by a cruel
creator and that everything was
ultimately meaningless,
but finite.
Lee,
terrible and,
and,
and generating nothing but pointless
suffering and tolstoy,
he said very,
very clearly that are,
uh,
um,
a man with conviction who came to that
conclusion could only continue to live
by diluting himself.
And he thought,
he thought he couldn't think him self
out of the proposition,
that his unwillingness to kill himself
was a form of cowardice once he had come
to that realization.
And so confession is about that.
And you know,
he tries to turn to the kind of religion
that characterize the Russian peasantry,
which would be,
you know,
in some sense an ignorant immersion in
beliefs that intellect had superseded.
But of course that wasn't available to
him.
And at the end of confession,
something happens to Tolstoy to redeem
him in a sense,
but all it is,
is his dream.
And he dreams of this.
He dreams that he's suspended over a
great abyss by a rope and as far down as
he can look,
there's nothing but empty space.
But then he turns to look up and he can
see the same rope above him stretching
up into the sky as far as it can reach.
And that's basically how the book ends.
And you know,
the inference is something like
tolstoy's dream revealed to him the
proposition that although there were a
bismal depths beneath mankind,
so to speak,
from a psychological perspective,
that we were also supported by something
infinite.
But it's not articulated like the whole
book just ends with the dream so well.
So Dostoyevsky lays out the,
the underground political movements that
were characteristic of late
the late 19 or the late 18 hundreds in
Russia.
And he describes the emergence of the
type of person who ends up after the
Russian revolution,
after the first world war,
becoming a committed and involved in the
collectivization process in Russia.
And it's virtually impossible to
overstate how terrible the
collectivization process was right from
its onset.
You know,
you'll still hear apologists for Marxism
and communism.
Talk about the fact that the Soviet
Union was captured by a cult of
personality under Stalin.
And that that's why the ethical
presuppositions of,
of,
of Marxism transformed into political
action became so corrupted.
But I think that's absolute nonsense and
I think it's nonsense of the most
dangerous and reprehensible type.
And I think that for two reasons,
the first reason was stolen was uh,
unbelievably murderous thug.
He pretty much killed everyone he knew,
including almost all of the,
they call them.
What were they?
I don't remember that the term.
They were old revolutionaries,
all of the
Bolsheviks who ran the revolution,
who didn't die during the revolution or
of natural causes afterwards,
they were all killed by Stalin.
He probably killed his wife.
He killed pretty much everybody he knew.
I mean,
he was,
and he was a like an underground
operative for Lenin during the
revolution itself,
where he learned to be committed from an
ideological perspective.
He'd come from quite an intensely
religious background,
committed from an ideological
perspective,
but then basically as acting as a
gorilla assassin during the revolution
itself.
And then later he rose to power it.
He certainly used Lennon's political
machinations as a machinations,
as a,
um,
as a template for his later activity.
But Lennon was no piker when it came to
extraordinarily
brutal activity motivated by Utopian
dreams.
Now,
what seemed to happen in some sense is
that you can imagine we're looking at
the political structure,
the political movements of whole
nations.
We're going down to the bottom to look
at it from a psychological perspective
instead of thinking it of it from an
economic perspective or a power
perspective.
In some sense it's a,
it's a union analysis of the rise of
political movements in,
in Europe and across the world with an
existential spin.
You can imagine that what classical
Christianity had set up for people was
not only a belief in,
in,
uh,
shared moral reality that,
that everyone was supposed to be
participating in,
but also some meaning for,
for some meaning for each individual's
life to some degree,
no matter how much they were suffering.
And then the promise of a kind of
perfection after death.
And of course people like Freud and
people like Marx considered that,
uh,
an illusion designed either to protect
the population from fear of death.
So that would be Freud's argument or
marks.
His argument would be,
well,
that that was,
uh,
a conspiracy in some sense,
promoted by the political and religious
elite to keep the people who are being
oppressed in their place.
Well,
of course there's some truth to both of
those,
but there's a difference between some
truth and that truth and any
extraordinarily complex phenomena has
multiple causal elements.
And those are two important ones because
of course an anxiety about death and
power are two very important
psychological phenomena.
And they play their role in determining
any important collective or individual
activity.
But you can't forget about the rest of
the,
uh,
the rest of the story now.
So this collapses and that leaves a
void.
And that void is a void in people's
souls,
so to speak.
It makes them nihilistic,
for example,
because they don't have any,
they can't see any ultimate meaning in
what they're doing.
But it also simultaneously makes them
more susceptible to utopian mass
movements of a rational type.
And of course,
that's exactly what happened with
regards to the Marxists.
And with regards to the fascist.
So what Hitler offered his followers in
collaboration with them because it
wasn't so much that Hitler told people
what he wanted them to think as it was,
that Hitler listened to what the crowd's
wanted and then told it back to them in
our collaboration that extended across
his entire rule because Hitler was a
great populist and he was very,
very good at receiving messages from the
audience.
But Hitler basically offered his pr,
his population,
the dream of racial superiority and
world domination,
you know,
as well as many,
many other things that went along with
that.
So,
and then of course,
Mark's offered his followers the idea
that the oppressed could shed their
chains and that everyone could unite
workers at intellectuals alike.
In particular,
it was the,
it was more the,
the owner,
the owning class,
the bourgeois as they're still called by
some people who were the,
the evil oppressors and the Union of
worker and intellectual would eventually
shepherd in a golden age where everyone
offered to society as much as they could
offer and took from society as much as
they need it.
Right.
And that's the famous phrase from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need,
which sounds wonderful.
You can,
I can understand why that would be an
attractive slogan,
but if you start to think about how that
would be administered in practice and
you really start to think it through,
you realize very,
very rapidly that it's a re it's a
recipe for absolute disaster,
partly because,
well,
how do you tell the difference between
your need and your need?
If your mother needs cancer surgery and
your genius brother needs to do go do
his phd,
who's need trump's while.
And that's just a trivial problem
because all of you have those competing
needs and how anybody is ever going to
adjudicate between the value of needs is
beyond cognitive comprehension.
It just can't be done.
Not without brutality,
especially because you know there's
limited resources.
And then the next question is,
well,
okay,
you're supposed to contribute according
to your ability.
How much ability do you have?
You know what that meant in practice?
That was that people were frequently
worked to death because the ability
isn't a definable entity.
You know,
and unless you have some sort of
complicated
and functional system to negotiate,
to allow people to negotiate amongst
themselves peaceably about what they're
going to offer and what they're going to
take,
you have to turn it over to something
like a centralized authority.
And you know,
it's just,
well,
you don't need much imagination to
understand that that would be an
absolute catastrophe.
And it was an absolute catastrophe.
Now,
one of the things that's really
interesting about Dostoyevsky's book,
the Devil's,
is that it's segues almost perfectly
into Alexandria soldier.
Nixon's description of the emergence of
the Russian prisoners,
the so Soviet prison camps after the
revolution.
So basically what happened,
and this was what Solzhenitsyn revealed
in the 1970s was that because the
communist system was so financially
untenable,
the principals just didn't work for all
sorts of reasons.
They,
the system ended up running basically on
a system of work camps and so much of
what the Russians produced,
the Soviets produced,
which wasn't very much by the way,
although they got industrialized very,
very rapidly,
was produced by people who were
basically enslaved,
and that's the only way the system could
continue to function.
Now,
soldier Nixon estimated that between 19
and nine 1919 which is basically the end
of the first world war and 1959 which is
basically when the Stalinist era came to
an end.
So that's only 40 years that 60 million
people were killed in the Soviet Union
as a consequence of internal repression.
I didn't count the Second World War.
Now people debate these figures and
soldier Nansen is surprisingly to me,
a controversial figure because I don't
see where the controversy is.
People complain about his numbers,
claiming that our death count of 60
million people over that period of time
is mathematically untenable,
but reason more reasonable estimates if
you want to put it that way,
put it up to 20 or 30 million.
And that the truth of the matter is that
no one knows.
And that even makes it worse.
I mean,
we do know,
for example,
that um,
the a sat collectivization in the 1920s
led to the creation of a agricultural
catastrophe
made worse by Stalin's peculiar economic
policies that killed 6 million people in
the,
in the Ukraine in the 1930s.
Now,
how many of you knew that?
How many of you know about the Ukrainian
famine?
How many didn't know?
Okay?
One thing you might want to ask yourself
is,
why the hell don't you know
it all?
You know,
lots of things about the mass death sin
in the 20th century,
but my experience has been that students
in the West know almost nothing about
what happened as a consequence of the
imposition of radical left wing
dictatorships.
And it's not trivial.
30 million in the Soviet Union.
Let's 6 million in Cambodia under Pol
Pot.
Pol Pot was trained at the sore bomb and
he took what he learned at the Sorbonne
from his radical left wing professors
and put it into practice in Cambodia.
Emptied out the cities because he had
learned that under Standard Marxists,
Dogma city people who are mostly
bourgeois were parasites on the workers.
He emptied the cities and killed 6
million people and then in China during
Mao's cultural revolution,
while no one really knows soldier nest
Solzhenitsyn's estimates were 100
million,
but you can take half that if you want.
These are massive,
massive numbers of people and part of
the reason that I think it's
reprehensible to pin the absolute
catastrophes of the Soviet state on the
style in this cult of personality was
that it didn't only happen in the Soviet
Union.
It happened with,
with catastrophic results in all sorts
of places where these economic policies
were implemented.
And I believe that the reason that
western students,
roughly speaking,
don't know about these things,
is that
the,
the intelligentsia of the West Europe
and North America,
we're going to save for the time being,
we're so heavily influenced by radical
left wing ideas from the 1920s well to
the present day that
these facts have never been made as,
uh,
have never been disseminated in his
thorough manner as is only appropriate.
So the French intellectuals,
for example,
from whom postmodernism derived,
uh,
people like John Paul Sartre and food co
and a very large group of French
intellectuals who were involved in the
student radical left student movements
in the late 1960s and who ended up
barricading the streets of Paris in
1968,
which is when the student movement sort
of peaked and then,
and then fell away.
Um,
they never apologized in any real sense
for there.
The fact of being enamored of,
well at least in part the policies of
Stalin and also the policies of Mau.
And there's no excuse for that.
So now the problem is of course,
is that left wing radical,
left wing political and economic ideas
are intellectually quite coherent.
Like they make sense once you accept a
certain set of axioms,
like from each according to his ability
to each according to his need.
You accept that axiom,
you accept the idea that the,
the capital class,
the capitalist class,
which is roughly anyone who owns
anything,
only owns what they owned because
they've stolen it from someone else so
that there's labor is productive but
nothing else is productive.
Everything else is a secondary
derivation of labor.
And you know,
that's an absolutely moronic economic
theory because obviously there's work
that has value,
there's work that has no value.
The fact that it's difficult has almost
no relationship to whether or not it has
value.
Unfortunately,
you know,
it's not like the political system or
the economic system is a perfect mirror
of effort.
It's not like that at all.
So
you might say that.
Okay,
well I would say really what happened in
the 20th century is once people stopped
worshiping an externalized Daddy,
they started to worship.
If they were intelligent,
they started to worship rational utopian
ideas and if they weren't as
intelligent,
they turned to the state like
identification with the state,
like the Nazis for example,
identification with the state as an
alternative source of collective power
and both of those were
in comprehensively devastated and we're
not done with it yet.
You know?
I mean,
one of the things that happened in the
Soviet Union and soldier Hinson,
one of whose I have you read one of his,
the chapters of the Gulag archipelago,
which is an amazing piece of writing.
What are the things that Solzhenitsyn's
soldier knits and points out is there
was this extensive prison camp system in
the Soviet Union that he called the
Gulag archipelago.
It was this chain of camps all across
the Soviet Union and if you were thrown
in there because you were a political
prisoner,
you are the worst kind of prisoner and
you could be thrown in there as a
political prisoner pretty much for
expressing any opinion whatsoever about
the state,
which is we're going to get back to that
as we tie this together with
existentialism.
Now the communists,
we regarded the murderers and the
rapists and the thieves as socially
friendly elements because it was a,
it was part of Marxist doctrine that the
only reason that you would become a
murderer or a thief or a rapist was
because you were part of the no press
class and your poverty was what
generated your crime.
So in some sense you couldn't be held
personally responsible for it.
And the upshot of that was that the
thieves and the rapists and murderers
ran the prisons.
Well,
Russia right now is a mafia state.
There's evidence,
for example,
that Putin is the richest man in the
world and he has
almost singular power over this or over
the affairs of the Soviet Union,
the former Soviet Union,
the Russians,
the Soviets killed anybody that had any
capacity for independent thought and
they raised the thugs to,
to the highest positions of authority.
And you guys are going to be dealing
with that for the rest of your life.
So if you think that that's changed,
you're wrong.
It hasn't changed at all.
Russia has just transformed from a
totalitarian communist state into a
Mafia state.
And that's a big problem.
Okay.
So we're not done with this yet.
And one of the things that soldier
Nixon,
he was,
this is why I use him as a psychological
thinker.
You know,
people generally consider Viktor Frankl,
um,
that the primary
existential psychologist or
psychiatrist,
now Victor Frankel came through the Nazi
prison counts and he developed logo
therapy as a consequence of that.
And logotherapy what part of the
principles of logotherapy were laid
forth in his book.
Man's search for meaning.
And one of Frankel's propositions was
essentially that because life is
suffering and,
and can be unbearable suffering that
it's necessary for people to have are
countervailing meaning to buttress
themselves against the tragedy of
existence.
And Frankl basically claimed,
and this is an existential claim that if
you,
that you could find that meaning and
collective belief,
but that there were terrible dangers
associated with that.
And so your moral obligation was to find
that meaning within the confines of your
own authentic individual life.
And you can see that sort of idea also
arising in the thought of Carl Rogers
for example.
And at the end,
it's also there in noon because of
course you don't believe that there was
this path he called individuation,
which was the flowering and
manifestation of the healthy and
integrated,
the deep,
healthy and integrated fundamental human
personality.
Of course,
piaget believed something similar,
although more collective because for
piaget,
the hammering of your psyche into
something resembling an integrated state
also had to be done in active concert
with all of the people around you.
You know,
because you are organizing yourself into
a coherent internal game where all your
little subpersonalities could find their
place.
Well simultaneously doing that with
other people over long spans of time.
But you can see this,
the theme,
there's a theme that emerges in all of
those thinkers.
And one of the themes is this,
that there are healthy pathways to
psychological development and the
existentialists in particular,
although this was also the case with
young,
worked as a secret agent for the
American government and provided the
president of the United States with
psychological reports on Hitler's state
of mind.
Now,
I wasn't even discovered until about
three years ago.
So all of these thinkers were concerned
about collective pathology and at the
same time concerned about individual
development.
And I don't think you can really
separate those things.
And the reason that I use soldier Nissen
has,
because he basically takes the same tack
as Viktor Frankl,
especially in the Gulag archipelago,
but it's a much more thoroughly
developed body of thought.
Like I'm an admirer of Frankel.
I think man,
search for meaning is amazing book,
but it's a good book.
Whereas the Gulag archipelago is a
devastatingly profound book.
They're not in the same,
they're not in the same league.
You know,
it's,
it's like
Solzhenitsyn is to Viktor Frankl.
What dusty Esky is to virtually any
other author.
You know,
there's this,
I don't know what it is about the Damn
Russians.
Maybe they're suffering has done
something to them over the hundreds of
years that it's been in place,
but they can produce,
people have unbelievable profundity as
well as,
you know,
crooks who are crooked and,
and murderous beyond comprehension.
So,
you know,
a soldier Nixon was very interested in
trying to understand what happened to
the Soviet Union was how that it could,
how could it transform itself into a
state that devoured the majority or a
vast minority of its citizens and often
the best of the citizenry.
I mean it was very common in the Soviet
Union and this is through the entire
Soviet block.
I mean you were required to be an
informer,
roughly speaking,
you were certainly taught to be an
informer at school.
And you know,
the Soviets made much of children who
were patriotic enough to turn in their
own parents.
You know,
they were held up as models of behavior
and it was very frequently the case that
if you denounced the neighbor,
that was a really good waste way for
your family to get their apartment.
And of course apartments were an
incredibly scarce supply and far too
many people generally lived in the same
locale.
And so if you were a three generation
family living in a one bedroom
apartment,
one of the most effective ways to get
your children a new apartment was to
denounce the neighbor down the hallway.
And as a reward,
you'd be given the apartment.
While you can imagine who would take
advantage of that kind of offer.
Now,
what happened in the 1920s during the
collectivization?
So here,
here's the idea of the serfs had been
emancipated in the late 18 hundreds and
they were basically feudal inhabitants
of parcels of land who were more or less
old by the no nobility.
It wasn't exactly slavery,
but because the serves has certain sets
of rights,
it was,
it was closer to slavery than to
anything else that you would
conceptualize from a modern perspective.
The serfs were emancipated in the late
18 hundreds.
Um,
actually at about the same time that
slavery was abolished in the United
States,
approximately the same period of time.
Anyways.
Um,
and so there was,
and of course that Russia had a very
rich aristocracy and it had a monarchy.
And so the idea that,
and then it went through the first world
war and,
and,
and was viciously demolish during the
first world war.
The idea that there was an underclass of
po of impoverished people and an
overclass of Eris to Craddick,
uh,
parasites was a compelling idea.
And it was a compelling idea in many
places other than Russia,
um,
especially at the turn of the century.
And that was partly because the
industrial revolution was brutal and
farm life was very difficult and there
was a massive gap between rich and poor.
And you know,
that was,
that was an attractive political
explanation.
And it had partial truth because of
course people are exploited and often
poor people are poor because they're
exploited.
But there's lots of other reasons to be
poor.
And rich people are sometimes rich
because they exploit.
But of course there's lots of other
reasons to be rich as well.
So,
um,
these ideas were put into practice by
the Bolshevik revolutionaries and one of
the most,
one of the most comprehensive
manifestations of that idea.
It took place in the 1920s when the
Soviets underwent a process that they
call d Kulak ization.
Now,
so imagine this.
So in the,
in the late 18 hundreds of the serfs
were emancipated.
And what that meant was that some people
started to own their own land.
You know,
they weren't nobles that owned it,
owned the states.
They were more like what we would
consider sort of middleclass farmers.
So they owned some land,
they own some animals.
They might own a half decent house in
the town and they might have done enough
or being fortunate enough to have
collected enough money and enough
property and enough stability so that
they could hire one or two people to
help them with their crops.
So they were by no means rich,
but they were,
they were the successful farming,
um,
class of the Soviet Union.
Okay.
Now the communists put forward the idea
that there is no way that you could have
a brick house in town and own more cows
than your neighbor and have some
productive land put aside.
And worst of all,
hire someone to work for you unless you
had essentially stolen that from your
neighbors.
So then the communists would send out
activists from the cities.
They would go to these towns and start
spreading this doctrine.
Okay,
now you gotta think this through.
Now who is going to be most responsive
to that doctrine?
Well,
it's going to be the most jealous,
useless,
jealous,
and resentful people in town.
It's going to be the guys that are
hanging around in the local bar,
drinking themselves,
have to death every day,
who feel that they've been totally
screwed over by life,
that are,
that hate.
The people who have come up with a
modicum of prosperity.
And then someone comes along and says,
Hey,
as far as our doctrine goes,
those people you hate,
there nothing better than thieves.
It's your moral and patriotic duty to
rise up and take everything they have.
And that's exactly what happened.
So during the D Kula causation process,
they're basically be mobs of jealous and
resentful thugs who would go into the
houses of these moderately prosperous
people who were actually the only people
in the Soviet Union who knew how to
farm.
And they took everything,
everything.
They go into their houses and strip
them.
Baron take all the animals.
And,
and then what the Communists did with
the Kulaks was they allowed them to
take,
they going to resettle them up mostly in
Siberia while there was no settlements
in Siberia.
So basically what they meant,
what that meant was hastily built rail
lines would take them in,
in the middle of the winter with their
families and dump them on the frozen
prairie where well,
all the children would die and everybody
more or less would freeze to death.
And so,
you know,
the Communists said,
well,
you could take two months worth of food
with you,
but of course they didn't make any
provisions for having that two months of
food.
And after you had gone through the
process of Dq,
like ization,
you can bloody well be sure that you
didn't have two months of food left that
you could take when you were suddenly
bundled onto the trains and driven to
the middle of nowhere.
Well,
you know,
after a number of years of that which,
which also involved the forced
collectivization of all the remaining
people,
the distribution of the land in
principle to everyone and then
collective farming while the entire
agricultural economy fell apart.
And that was particularly the case in
the Ukraine,
which is a very,
very fertile part of the world.
And which was the breadbasket of of
Russia,
roughly speaking,
while everybody starved,
the Communists had to put up posters
telling people that eating their
children was wrong.
They would kill people if they went out
in the fields after the harvest.
So they go out with their big harvesting
machines,
vacuum up all the grain,
ship it to the cities because the cities
were also starving and leave nothing for
the people behind.
And then if you went out there in the
field,
like if you are a mother and your child
was starving to death and you went out
there in the field and you picked up
individual kernels of grain so that you
gathered them in a cop and bring them
home to feed their,
affect your family,
that was an executable crime because you
were supposed,
you're stealing from the state if you're
going to go out there and bloody well
pickup the wretched little kernels that
are left,
you know,
half crushed into the ground that it was
your moral obligation to turn those over
to the state because I suppose that was
part of your ability and the needs
somewhere else was greater.
Well,
Solzhenitsyn was very interested in how
the hell this sort of thing could even
happen.
You don't want because,
and he wasn't interested in precisely
from a political perspective.
I mean I would say he started being
interested in it from a political
perspective,
analyzing the actions of people like
Lenin and Stalin.
He wrote a very interesting book on
Lennon,
which was one of the first documents
that made lennon out to be the same sort
of person that Stalin was,
even though I think now the historical
evidence for that is crystal clear,
but it solves your nets and ended up
more by doing a psychological analysis.
And that's because as he considered what
had happened to his country,
he couldn't escape the proposition that
the reason it had become so corrupt was
because all of the individuals within it
had allowed themselves to become
corrupt.
And so one,
if you're wondering,
for example,
how you know your political system has
become corrupt or,
or let's,
let's put it differently,
how you know that any system that you
happen to be embedded in has become
corrupt.
One way of assessing that,
judging that is to determine for
yourself whether or not you're allowed
to say what you think.
You know what I mean?
You can genuinely think something
without it being right,
obviously.
But if you genuinely think something
that's your truth and you know in the
marketplace of free ideas,
everyone is allowed to express their
truth,
that that doesn't mean everyone's right.
It doesn't mean that you have any right
to have people listen to you.
It doesn't grant you any access to
power,
but at least you get to say what you
think.
And if that's withheld from your,
you're punished for it.
You can bloody well be certain that the
system has started to take a vicious
turn towards oppression and repression
and that the outcome of that's going to
be bad.
Even if your thoughts are reprehensible,
you should be allowed to put them
forward.
Not least because the rest of the
society needs to know where the
dangerous wing nuts are so that you can
so that the ideas can be brought up,
you know,
out in the open and disqualified,
so freedom of speech encompasses the
freedom to say the most outrageous
things.
Just so everybody knows what you're
thinking.
Because if you can't say it,
that doesn't mean you're not thinking
it.
It's just going to go underground and
fester there like a Freudian repressed
thought.
So freedom speech has nothing to do with
protecting the kind of speech that is
necessarily pro social.
It's exactly the opposite of that is you
want everybody to say what they're
thinking because the end,
you know what they're thinking and it's
and well,
and it's also often the case that people
can't come to the truth unless they're
allowed to express their untruth and
have that,
you know,
criticized in the in public forums.
So Solzhenitsyn's conclusion was that
there was no way that the terrors of the
Soviet state could have got the foothold
that they got unless individual people
were willing to falsify that nature of
their own experience.
And in the Gulag archipelago,
he basically,
he basically describes the society.
It's 2,700 pages long,
this book and it's little tiny type.
It's a very,
very comprehensive examination.
He basically shows you story after story
tells you story after story of how
people falsified their experience in the
service of the state.
And so the story is basically something
like this.
He said,
this is what happens when you give your
God given sole over to human dogma.
So the basic idea is,
well,
you're left and an you left in the
sphere that it is is has the absence of
a well defined meaning.
So that's a consequence of the collapse
of the previous belief systems.
And because you're torn apart by that in
some sense,
you don't know where to turn.
And one direction is of course
nihilistic.
And the other direction perhaps is
totalitarian.
Now,
another direction might be that you try
to figure things out on your own and
still live a life that's truthful and,
and,
and that has integrity.
But we're going to leave that alone for
a moment because it's,
it's difficult to even conceptualize
that might exist if you've already
swallowed the presupposition that all
the values have fallen apart.
You turn to totalitarianism.
Okay,
well it tells you what to think and it
tells you how to act.
It tells you how your society should be
structured,
but it does some things that are even
more subtle and subtly destructive than
that because what it also does is
positive future utopia,
which is an organization of the state
where everyone has everything they want
permanently.
Now Dostoyevsky when he wrote notes from
underground,
he basically said,
well,
this was way before the communist
revolution.
He said he was talking about these sorts
of Utopian,
uh,
egalitarian communitarians.
He said they've got human beings
completely wrong,
right,
right from the bottom up.
Because if you took the typical person,
he says,
if you gave them everything they
possibly want to,
to eat so that all they had to ever do
is eat delicious cakes and they didn't
have any other responsibilities than
what did he say,
uh,
indulging in the continuation of the
human species.
And so that if they were so happy that
if you put them under water,
nothing but bubbles of bliss would float
up to the surface.
The first thing that people who were
putting in that situation would do would
be to wander around smashing things just
so that something unexpected and
interesting would happen.
You know,
it's a brilliant critique of utopianism
because it's exactly right.
He said he basically Dostoyevsky said
people are so crazy that they'd rather
be subjected to inconvenient and
unexpected occurrences than just to lay
there all soporific with bliss.
And so that there was something wrong
with the whole utopia notion right from
the get go because that's just not what
people are like.
They'd rather have interesting trouble
than non interesting perfection,
you know?
And I think that's an incredibly
powerful idea.
But anyways,
you can just think about that in
relationship to your own character.
I mean,
how often do you do something that's
troubled just to see what happens?
I mean,
it's exactly what people are like.
You know,
even chimpanzees,
juvenile champs,
if they see an old male sleeping
underneath the tree,
they'll go and poke them with a stick
just to see what happens,
you know?
And it's like,
well,
if you can't see human humanity and that
sort of behavior,
there's something wrong with you.
So,
but the utopians offered this vision of
the future,
which was basically paradise on earth,
but they also proposed that it was
something that could be attained through
certain types of,
you know,
direct political action,
which usually meant,
well fix your neighbor up or even worse,
man steal what he has because he
shouldn't have it anyways.
And the problem with the Utopian Vision
essentially was that if my theory is
associated with a future utopian,
a logical way,
so I can make a case to you that if you
do this and we do that and they do this
and we organizing things this way,
then we'll our shear in a period of
prosperity that's almost heavenly in its
in its promise.
The problem with that is it means we can
do any bloody thing,
bloody thing we want right now because
the end product is so valuable that it
justifies it.
And so what happens is that the Utopian
vision turns into a rationale for the
most destructive forms of behavior in
the here and now.
And then when someone's called to task
for,
it's like,
what the hell do you think you're doing?
You know,
they'll say something like,
well,
you can't make an omelet without
breaking eggs,
you know,
and that's all well and good if you
happen to be making the Omelet,
but it's not so damn good if you happen
to be one of the eggs.
And there were plenty of eggs broken on
the way to,
you know,
the Soviet vision of success while,
and you know there's good evidence
stolen.
By the time the mid 1950s came around,
there's pretty decent evidence from the
KGB archives that he was preparing to
launch a thermonuclear war against
Europe.
I mean,
he'd already killed God only knows how
many million by that point,
a few more hundred million.
We're really going to weigh that heavily
on his conscience.
The last book I read on stolen,
which was published,
which was called stolen.
It was written by a guy who had access
to the KGB and Communist Party archives.
He claimed that Khrushchev and three
other people killed Stellan in the late
1950s to stop him from invading Europe.
So I mean,
you know,
in the battle between the communist
utopians and the West,
we came this close to wiping everything
out several times.
So
now what happened in some sense was
this,
is that this theory was laid out to
cover the world.
So the Marxist theory was presented
itself as a scientific theory and
inevitable theory of history.
And the theory of history was that the
warfare between the oppressed and the
oppressor was the primary fact of life.
And that that needed to transform itself
into a egalitarian utopia.
And that there were certain states that
political states that mankind would have
to go through to reach that end.
Okay.
So that was basically the theory.
And part of the theory was that in order
to get to that point,
then resources had to be distributed
equally to all,
which sounds fine in principle.
But then again,
the devil's always in the details and
how to distribute resources equally is
by no means self evident.
You know,
part of the reason that the English came
up with the idea of the free market,
this is Adam Smith fundamentally,
is because Smith figured out that trying
to figure out what things were worth is
so complicated that you can't actually
calculate it.
So then we would say,
well,
what's your coat worth?
I'd say,
well,
would you give me your code for $5
$2
thousand dollars okay,
so,
but to say the point being is that,
you know,
there's no way of establishing the worth
of things because the worth of one thing
is it's worth in relationship to all
other things of worth.
Like it's a continual interaction
between all things of worth.
And the only way you can make that
calculation is by letting people,
individual people make micro choices and
that the value of things is established
as a consequence of a hundred billion
micro choices.
We'd call that in the modern world would
call something that something that's
something like distributed cognition.
You know,
it's like you're outsourcing a price
decision to the marketplace.
What's this thing worth?
Well the answer is whatever people will
trade for it and it's not a copout.
It's,
it's an illustration indication of the
fact that you can't come up with a
computation that will allow you to
determine what something is worth.
So I mean,
I can give you an example of that from
my own life trying to figure out what
something is worth.
I developed some software to help people
hire employees and we did the
mathematical calculations and figured
out that if people use this particular
software instead of going through a
interview process,
which doesn't work very well,
that it would basically,
if they used,
if they gave it to 10 people to select
one employee,
that it would save them about 35% of the
salary of the hired person per year.
So if you hired someone who was being
paid $100,000 then the return on
investment would be $35,000 a year.
And we could sell this for say,
well,
we didn't know what,
how much do you charge for the tests
then?
So you might say,
well,
if it's $35,000 a year,
you're going to have this person around
for four years,
because that's how long the average
person stays in their job.
That's $150,000 and so then you only
have to use 10 tests.
And so maybe we could take a half of the
first year,
so that'd be $17,000 so it'd be $1,750 a
test.
And you'd get like a 30 what is it?
You get an eight times return on your
investment.
Well you should be just jumping at that.
Well,
it doesn't work like that at all.
We ended up having to sell it for about
$20 a test and we could hardly sell it
to anyone because well,
for reasons that are far too complex to
go into.
But my point is is that it's impossible
to make a pricing decision.
It's really,
really difficult.
And to think that you could make a
conscious and preprogrammed pricing
decision for every single commodity is
completely insane.
And that's what they tried to do in the
Soviet Union.
And I read at one point that the central
price pricing committee had to make
10,000 pricing decisions a day.
Well you can't even come up with the
price of one.
You've put things on Kijiji,
you know,
it's like,
well,
what's it worth?
Well you look at what everyone else is
paying for it,
roughly speaking,
and then it depends on how quickly you
want to sell it and what kind of shape
it's in.
And you know it's complicated and you
have a pricing guideline,
you just have to look the damn thing up.
It's still hard to figure out what the
price is.
But imagine you have no comparative
information at all.
What's a hypodermic needle worth?
Well,
I guess it depends on whether you need
it to inject the penicillin that's going
to save your life or if you're just
putting it in your cupboard to store it,
but it's a complicated decision.
All right,
so anyways,
this Utopian scheme was set up and we're
acting on the proposition that people
used it at least in part as a
replacement for their alternative for
their old belief systems,
which I think is a perfectly reasonable
proposition,
but we're also going to take a
psychoanalytic approach and we're going
to say,
well,
it also allowed people to manifest bad
faith because if you're worth can be
determined by how good a car you are in
the fascist or communist machinery,
it pretty much alleviates you have any
responsibility that you have to have for
your own life.
So that for,
for every positive reason that you might
join a utopian movement,
there's a negative reason which as well
you can benefit from.
It's exploitive nature and you don't
have to take any responsibility.
While Solzhenitsyn and Frankl both
talked about that a lot,
as did Nisha,
but Franklin soldier knits and are more
interesting because they actually
happened to live through the imposition
of systems like that and could see them
from the inside.
Solzhenitsyn's first observation was
Marxist economics didn't work well.
That was a big problem because it was
supposed to work and not only was it
supposed to work,
it was supposed to work perfectly.
And what that basically meant was that
if it didn't work,
you only had one of two options.
You could either abandon the dam system
and start to complain about the fact
that you had to line up for bread for
four hours a day,
which was perfectly typical daily
activity for people.
For example,
in Poland and in Russia before the wall
came down,
everything costs nothing but there
wasn't anything to buy.
So it wasn't very much of a bargain.
And instead of paying for your bread
with money,
you just paid for it.
With time.
You stayed in line for two hours or
three hours or five hours.
And when you got to the front of the
line at the department store,
you took whatever the hell was there
because you didn't even know what it was
that you were going to be buying when
you joined the lineup.
And so it wasn't like it was free.
He had just paid for it with your time.
So soldier knits and noted that what
happened as the system continued to
manifest it's counterproductive
properties was that either people had
the choice of saying,
oh,
this isn't working worth a damn.
There must be something rotten in
Denmark or pretending that everything
was all right in lying about everything.
And that's what they did.
They lied about everything.
And so we've got to,
you've got the situation up to the point
where in East Germany,
before the wall came down,
one out of every three people was a
government informer stop man.
If you had a family of six people,
two of them were telling the government
what you were talking about at dinner
and that was their duty.
And so what that meant in these
societies was no one ever said anything
that they meant ever.
And if they did the probability that the
KGB was going to kick down the door at
four in the morning and take them off to
the central prison before dumping them
in some damn camp where they'd never see
anybody they ever knew for the rest of
their life was extraordinarily high.
So you watched everything you said and
everything you thought around your wife,
around your brother,
around your sister,
around your children,
and the whole system ground onward in a
mire of absolute deception and lie and
soldier knits his point as well.
And this is one of Frankel's main
points,
is that if people had had,
if people had decided to stop lying,
the system would have ground to a halt.
But that isn't what people did.
They just kept lying.
Now he noticed when he was in the prison
camps,
because he was in them for a long time.
He did encounter people inside the camps
like Frankl did,
who were absolutely unwilling to falsify
their experience.
So for example,
one of the things that had to happen if
you were arrested by the kgb and
sentenced to a prison camp was that it
was necessary for you to sign a
confession.
And that's so peculiar.
You think,
ah,
they're going to arrest the arbitrarily
and put you on trial for trumped up
nonsense.
Why couldn't they just forge your
signature?
It's like,
why did they care if you confessed?
And the answer to that was,
well,
it was part of the way the system kept
itself validated because the people who
were torturing you could justify the
torture if you agreed that you are
actually at fault.
And so rather than face the fact that
they were just doing something corrupt,
innocent people,
they'd extract a confession out of use
so that they could convince themselves
that you deserved exactly what you got.
A soldier in Edson said at one time that
one person who stopped lying could bring
down a tyranny.
Now,
that's a pretty radical statement,
but you know,
when he wrote the Gulag archipelago,
I mean he memorized that damn book when
he was in one of the prison camps
because they didn't give him pencil or
paper.
And even if they did,
they wouldn't have been able to carry
the damn manuscript around.
So he basically memorized at 2,700
pages,
you know,
written at the volume of a very loud
scream.
And when he got out of the prison camps,
he had two copies of it typed up,
one by one typist in one by another.
They didn't know each other.
The KGB broke into the one type is Soman
stole the manuscript and she killed
herself.
Then the,
well,
and you can understand why,
you know,
when she thought this was a tremendously
valuable piece of work and she thought
it was the only copy and they destroyed
it.
Well,
he couldn't even tell her that there was
another one because they would have got
it too.
Well.
And then it was exported to the West in
unpublished forum and published in
English to begin with.
And it was an absolute bomb shell like,
and it was published in 1974 was at that
point,
anyone who had any moral integrity
whatsoever had,
who was also literate,
read that and said,
Oh,
okay,
game over all those propositions.
They're wrong beyond belief.
And that part of what we thought might
be possible is done.
Well,
you know,
that happened to some degree.
It communism lost a tremendous amount of
its intellectual credibility.
And that was part of the reason that it
fell over in 1989 but you know,
it's not like everybody has shaken
there.
No,
it's not as if everyone's faith in that
sort of thing is being shaken.
You know,
there's this massive stream of Marxist
utopianism that's still running through
postmodernism and that's,
that's,
you know,
made its way to Western universities all
over the world.
So despite all of this,
despite these tens of millions of deaths
and this total moral corruption,
and no one even knows about it,
and I don't understand that it's
completely,
it's completely unacceptable.
It's the biggest lesson of the 20th
century,
you know,
and we hear a lot about the Holocaust
and no wonder it was a truly terrible
thing.
But there's all these other events of
the 20th century that were absolutely
catastrophic and they're not part of
general knowledge.
And you have to ask yourself why?
Because if we can't learn from that,
if we can't learn from all those tens of
millions of people who were tortured to
death and,
and,
and ruined in political prisons,
like you gotta ask yourself,
can we actually learn anything?
I'm going to read you some of the things
that Solzhenitsyn wrote.
He doesn't say the name of this person.
It's in,
it's in dashes.
Someone he meant he met either in a
camper afterwards,
he told how executions were carried out
at a dock,
a camp on the [inaudible] river.
They would take the opposition members
with their things out of the camp
compound on a prisoner transport at
night and outside the compound stood the
small house of the third section.
Okay.
These were people who were opposing the
communist ideology.
The condemned men were taken into a room
one at a time and they're,
the camp guard sprang on them.
Their mouths were stuffed with something
soft and their arms are bound with cords
behind their backs.
Then they were led out into the
courtyard where harnessed carts were
waiting.
The bound prisoners were piled on the
carts five to seven at a time and driven
off to the Gorkha,
the camp cemetery on arrival.
They were tipped into big pits that had
already been prepared and buried alive,
not out of brutality.
No.
It had been calculated than would
dragging and lifting the mood was much
easier and more efficient to cope with
living people.
Then with corpses,
the work went on for many nights at a
dock and that is how the moral political
unity of our party was achieved.
Okay.
This is from Frankel.
This is the concentration camps in Nazi
Germany.
Okay.
These.
Those were the size of cities,
by the way.
I mean,
when you think of camp,
I don't know what image it brings up in
your mind,
but you know,
you might think of an enclosure the size
of a city block or something like that,
but that's not right.
These places where the size of cities,
because there was tens of thousands of
people in them.
The most ghastly moment of the 24 hours
of camp life was the awakening when Adh
is still nocturnal hour,
the three shrill blows of a whistle,
Taurus pitiless,
Leigh fermor exhausted and from the
longings in our dreams.
We then began the tussle with our wet
shoes into which we could scarcely force
our feet,
which were sore and swollen with edema,
and there were the usual moans and
groans about petty troubles such as the
snapping of wires,
which replaced shoe laces.
One morning I heard someone who my new
to be brave and dignified cry like a
child because he finally had to go to
the snowy marching grounds in his bare
feet as his shoes were too shrunk and
for him to wear in these ghastly
moments,
I found a little bit of comfort,
a small piece of bread,
which I draw out of my pocket and
munched with absorbed delight.
This is soldier Knutsen.
So in these camps,
people were set out to work and it would
depend on where they were,
what they were working on,
but maybe it was the digging of a canal
or maybe they were setting up a factory
or,
or they were doing something that
required the generally required intense
physical effort
and each of these camps had a ha they,
they had a,
a goal right there was established from
above.
It's like a five year plan.
Your camp is to produce this much in
this period of time.
And then if you didn't produce that much
in that period of time,
then the people who ran the camp,
we're going to be held accountable,
which generally meant that they were
going to be put in some camp themselves.
And so there was every reason to drive
people to their death in order to
fulfill the work norms.
And when that didn't happen,
they just falsified the records anyways
because what the hell was their choice?
And Solzhenitsyn talks about how they
got around the rules
in called lower than 60 degrees below
zero days were written off.
In other words,
on such days,
the record showed that the workers have
not gone out to work well.
So then you can tell a bit about the
benevolence of the Soviet state.
If it was 55 below,
well then you could go out to work,
but if it was 60 below,
you got to stay home.
While that isn't even how it worked.
In other words,
on 60 below days,
the record showed that the workers had
not gone to work,
but they chased them out anyways and
whatever they squeezed out of them on
those days was added to the other days.
Thereby raising the percentages,
underserved biomedical section road off
those who froze to death on such cold
days on some other basis,
and the ones who were left who could no
longer walk and we're straining every
sinew to crawl along and all fours on
the way back to camp,
the convoy simply shot so that they
wouldn't escape before they could come
back to get the
skeleton.
Had a group of people,
hundreds of thousands of people dig a
canal in the 1930s and I unfortunately,
I can't remember the name of the canal,
but some 300,000 people froze to death
digging it with spades and shovels in
the middle of the Russian winter.
And when it was finished,
it was so shallow that none of the ships
that were planned to go up and down it
could use it,
but it got finished even though it was
the middle of the winter.
This is from William Blake.
Oh rose,
thou art sick.
The invisible worm that flies in the
night and the howling storm have found
out diabet of crimson joy and his dark
secret.
Love does die.
Life destroy.
This is another story from social nets
in about a women's camp.
He's standing in another camp watching
this occur because the women of course
were put into camp separate from the man
fire,
the branches,
crackle,
and the night wind of late autumn blows
the flame of the bonfire back and forth.
The compound is dark.
I'm alone at the bar and fire and I can
bring it still some more carpenter
shavings.
The compound that I man is a privileged
one,
so privileged that it is almost as if I
were out in freedom.
This is an island of paradise.
This is the Marfino [inaudible],
which was a scientific institutes
staffed with prisoners in its most
privileged period.
No one is overseeing me,
calling me to a cell,
chasing me away from the bonfire.
And even then it is chilly in the
penetrating wind,
but she who has already been standing in
the wind for hours,
her arms straight down,
her head drooping,
weeping,
then growing numb and still,
and then again she begs pityingly
citizen chief,
please forgive me,
I won't do it again.
The wind carries her moan to me just as
if she were moaning next to my ear.
The citizen chief at the gate house
fires up his stove and does not answer.
This was the gate house of the camp next
to us from which workers came into our
compound to lay water pipes and repair
the old ramshackle seminary building
across from me beyond the artfully
intertwined many stranded barbed wire
barricade and two steps away from the
gate house beneath a bright lantern
stood the punished girl head hanging the
wind tugging at her gray work skirt,
her feet growing numb from the cold and
the thin scarf over her head.
It had been warm during the day when
they had been digging a ditch on our
territory.
And another girl slipped down into a
ravine,
crawled her way to the Vladi Keno
highway and escaped.
The guard had bungled and Moscow city
buses ran right along the highway.
When they caught on,
it was too late to her,
so they raised the alarm,
a mean dark major arrived in shouted
that if they fail to catch the girl,
the entire camp would be deprived of
visits and parcels for a whole month
because of her escape and the women
brigadiers went into a rage and they
were all shouting.
One of them in particular who kept
viciously rolling her eyes.
Oh,
I hope they catcher the bitch.
I hope they take scissors and clip,
clip all,
take off all of her hair in front of the
lineup.
This wasn't something she had thought up
for herself.
This is the way they punished women in
the ghoulag,
but the girl who is now standing outside
the gate house in the cold had sighed
and said instead,
at least she can have a good time out
and freedom for all of us.
The jailer overheard what she said and
now she was being punished.
Everyone else.
It'd be taken off to the camp,
but she had been set outside there to
stand at attention in front of the gate
house.
This had been at 6:00 PM and now it was
11:00 PM she tried to shift from one
foot to another,
but the guards stuck out his hand and
shouted,
stand at attention,
horror or else it will be worse for you
and now she was not moving.
Only weeping.
Forgive me,
citizen chief,
let me into the camp.
I won't do it anymore,
but even in the camp,
no one was about to say to her,
all right,
idiot,
come on in.
The reason they were keeping her out
there any way for so long was that the
next day was Sunday and she wouldn't be
needed for work such as straw,
blonde,
naive,
uneducated slip of a girl.
She'd been in prison for some spool of
thread.
What a dangerous thought.
You expressed their little sister,
they want to teach you a lesson for the
rest of your life.
Fire,
fire.
We fought the war and we looked into the
bonfires to see what kind of victory it
would be.
The wind wafted a glowing husk from the
bonfire.
Okay?
To that flame in you,
girl.
I promise the whole world will read
about you.
Okay.
This is from Milton.
Paradise lost for Wednesday,
but from the author of all ill could
spring so deep,
a Melis to confound the race of mankind
in one route and earth with hell to
mingle and involve,
done all to spite the great creator.
What are the political implications of
existential psychology?
If you lie,
you corrupt the system.
If you ally enough,
the system becomes so corrupt that it
turns on you and becomes murderous.
So the price of freedom as far as the
existentialists are concerned,
and this is buttressed by the historical
knowledge that they garner during the
20th century,
was that you have a moral obligation.
You have a moral obligation to speak the
truth,
to maintain the integrity of the state
as well as fostering your own
psychological integration.
We'll see you on Tuesday.